[Music]
a few days ago this was a pristine
forest now it's totally singed areas
still on fire and this is a picture
which is repeated thousands and
thousands of times across south west
france we need to be prepared for
experiencing a lot more of these
wildfires
as the climate changes as it gets hotter
and drier
climate change impacts wildfires like
these and makes them more likely here's
why
a wildfire needs three things the right
weather some fuel and a spark
if climate change didn't exist we'd
still have wildfires in fact they're a
crucial part of the ecosystem as they
clear dead organic matter
but without global warming there would
be far fewer fires and they'd be less
likely to spread as far
climate change brings more drought and
higher temperatures meaning flames start
more easily and are harder to
contain the oxygen in the hot dry windy
weather helps to feed the flames
meaning they can quickly get out of
control
[Music]
in current conditions these fires are
self-perpetuating
they're burning more intensely and for
longer than nature's been able to adapt
to which means it's harder for forests
to regenerate
that leaves space for more flammable
plants like grasses and shrubs to move
in
perfect tinder for future fires
hot air acts like a sponge it draws out
water from the soil plants and trees
which crisps everything up and creates
the perfect kindling for a fire
the hotter the air the more water it's
able to hold so when there's a heat wave
all the organic matter on the ground is
quickly dried to a crisp add in
long-term temperature increases in
global warming and even deep rooted
trees and plants can dry out
creating a whole lot of fuel for the
fires
these fires can ignite naturally simply
by the intense heat of the sun
but more often they're caused by us
a discarded cigarette or a campfire that
gets out of control in these hot and dry
conditions we're likely to see more of
these types of incidents and we need to
be prepared for them this is not going
to go away this threat is not going to
go away
wildfires are now happening more often
they're spreading further and they're
burning through areas we wouldn't
necessarily expect to be hit
without drastic action on climate change
we can only expect to see more
devastation like this in the future
you